ce qu'on appelle ça une crête de coq
c'est pour faire étanchéité entre les
deux faîtières et du coup c'est le petit
côté artistique sur ce chantier de
l'église Saint-Martin de Sartrouville
Julien Sartori peaufine les derniers
détails ce mercredi 15 mars l'équipe
couverture s'affaire pour achever
l'arrière de la toiture de cet édifice
classé au Monument Historique là on
vient de finir l'abside je suis en train
de faire les crêpes de coq là pour finir
étanchéité de la du faîtage on essaye
vraiment de travailler à l'ancienne tout
en essayant d'améliorer pour éviter les
risques de fuite édifiant l'an 1009 sur
une butte dominance Sartrouville cette
église emblématique de la commune a
débuté ses importants travaux en janvier
2022 suite à de nombreuses fissures et
déformations la stabilité du clocher
n'était plus assurée une reconstruction
était nécessaire nous avons d'abord
procédé au démontage de la de la flèche
et puis en partant du haut d'abord le
coq puis en redescendant pierre par
pierre en les notant on les en les
mesurant de façon à les reproduire à
l'identique avec une pierre identique
également qui on vient d'une carrière de
Saint-Maximin à une quinzaine de mètres
du sol ce sculpteur réalise les
ornements sur le clocher de l'église
grâce à ce modèle en plâtre il va
tailler dans la roche la statue de ce
lion réalisée en hommage au futur roi de
France pendant la guerre de Cent ans
Charles V a fait démonter ce que cette
flèche pour éviter que les Anglais
prennent possession 8 ans après il a
fait remonter cette flèche et donc ils
avaient mis à cette occasion là le
blason de Charles V qui était dauphin à
cette époxy la sculpture originale ayant
disparu au moment des travaux seule une
photo du début du 20e siècle et un
document papier permettent cette
création c'est toujours la même démarche
ce n'est pas ne pas inventer c'est de
restituer au plus juste ce que les
anciens compagnons avaient réalisé à
l'époque dans le courant du mois d'avril
les trois cloches retrouveront leur
place d'origine au sein de la flèche le
vaste chantier de l'église Saint-Martin
devrait se terminer en 2024